[Music]
mark's with us in new york city hey mark
welcome to the ramsay show what's up in
your world
hey dave thank you for having me on the
show sure he'll make it very simple uh
over the past few years i've made some
poor financial decisions and i've ended
up in 150 000 of credit card debt good
lord what'd you buy
i didn't buy i didn't buy anything i um
i was going through a phase drug
addiction and things file that spiraled
out of control i had a very you know i i
was very good with money in in
in a past life and i had a high credit
score and i blew through everything
now the reason that happened to me was
because my father died a tragic death
and i uh i went through a lawsuit which
recently settled so
i just don't know how to get my life
back in order i am employed gainfully
employed
however it's just so overwhelming what
do you mean i
uh just under 200.
cool how long have you been driving
what's that how long have you been
driving what three years three years
what was it
uh prescription painkillers okay how old
are you i was
i i'm going to turn 31. okay
i'm sorry about your dad how long ago
did he pass
uh october 2017.
[Music]
obviously your hero
no well yeah of course i mean
well i mean if it was devastating to you
he meant a lot to you yeah
um
what other uh what other family and
friends and support supportive you got
around you while you're walking out your
sobriety
uh i mean
everyone is behind me um
i mean it's like really a thing of the
past i mean i'm so blessed i mean
i mean you got good support you know
what i uh good support i i didn't know
the dangers you know i was i was uh
getting some surgery during the time i
saw how they died and
i mean
it just snaps you become dependent on
these things oh yeah they're good to you
i mean
it's embarrassing to even say i mean uh
goodness i mean oh when you're hurting
and you're not hurting anymore they're
good to you and it just it compounds i
know i've heard about it
all right i'll tell you what i think you
got the chemistry to make it uh you just
need a game plan that's going to give
you a little bit of hope can you hang on
with me through the break and let's work
on that all right we're talking with
mark in new york city makes 200 000
years got 150 000 in credit card debt
ran it up during uh three years ago he's
been drive for three years off of his
prescription drug addiction uh which
occurred after the loss of his dad
tragically he's in his 30s and wanting
to know if he's bankrupt is that a fair
summary of what you told me so far sir
uh yes there's one other x factor uh
because you know with my dad's situation
i recently settled a lawsuit
so now i have a a settlement and uh
i just don't know how to
best use this as a tool to repair what
i've done
okay and how much is the settlement am i
uh
i i really want to say in the air but at
seven figures
over a million
yeah okay all right cool when you and
your debts are 150 000
yes okay well obviously you're not
bankrupt obviously you're not bankrupt
no no sir i'm
very blessed okay all right so um uh i
misunderstood the the question then okay
because
you can't file bankruptcy the judge
would just take some of your money and
pay your bills it wouldn't and laugh at
you you know he wouldn't do it so um
so the 150 000 uh is it all current or
are you behind on it or what no
no i haven't i haven't even looked at it
in in three years i mean
part of those three years i was kind of
out of commission yeah so the current
150 000 figure comes from the last time
you looked at it or recently you just
called all of them and got the new
numbers
uh
that's the last time i looked at it i i
don't even know where the debt is or who
bought it or or
where where it is in the debt
yeah all right but you have an idea
where it started
yeah how many different how many
different credit cards
about five
okay
all right
uh are you doing uh
uh
uh anonymous are you doing 12-step
no no no that it's uh i listen i went
down that road and that was part of that
three years thing um
i just
you know i grew up catholic i just
returned to
my my faith in christ and and what's
important to me
but as far as spending my life in a uh
i wasn't asking you to do that i was
just ask trying to get context to where
your head is
because because 12 steppers have a
framework in which they look at things
and that's i was trying to see if that's
what you were doing that's okay no
problem i'm not trying to sell you on
twitter i think it's great for some
people it's just it's not for me okay
that's fine you're dry i'm going with
dry okay
that's a big thing you stay sober i'm
not arguing with you
um the uh
money in heart
so what you've got to do is you have
some hard work to do
you've got a business to run here and
your business is
uh i'm gonna let's just pretend i'm not
going to but let's pretend i hired you
for a hundred thousand dollars a year as
a part-time job in addition to your
regular job and your job for a hundred
thousand dollars a year is go back and
clean up this guy's mess named mark
and your job how would you do that you
would go back to the last source of
anything you had and you would figure
out okay the you know i borrowed 12 000
from citibank and then i contact
citibank and they've added on 73 million
fees and now it's 22 000 so i've got two
figures i got a 12 and i got a 22. okay
and then i do the same thing with uh jp
morgan i do the same thing with whoever
wherever you got the stinking cards okay
and you go back and you try to source
them they've probably sold them now
here's what i want you to understand
if they have sold them to a debt buyer
which they likely have if it's
three-year-old debt
a debt buyer will buy that money
approximately a nickel on the dollar
and so they're going to buy
a 1 000 credit card debt for 50 bucks
got it
got it and you are then then they dump
you into a phone room
a boiler room 9 000 people in cubicles
with fluorescent lights calling people
all day long trying to get money out of
them and couldn't get a better job so
they've got a really bad job called
credit card collector it sucks as a job
and they don't last very long on the job
and they lie and they yell and they do
anything they can do to get money out of
you and so that's who you're dealing
with on the other end pretty much scum
of the earth
okay
and so your job then is to say okay you
paid a nickel on the dollar you're
trying to get two dollars for every
dollar that was owed we're not going to
do that i will pay you today what the
original balance was as settlement in
full
and you can do that easily you have
plenty of money
and you get it in writing from them they
will do that deal all day long they'll
probably take a quarter on the dollar
but you're probably going to argue with
them a lot more and you have the money
to pay your bill so you legitimately
borrowed twelve thousand dollars you've
got over a million you can pay the guy
twelve thousand dollars okay so you pay
them twelve thousand bucks it's what you
owe
and so but you don't pay them 22 000
because that's what they're going to try
to stick you with is all the stuff they
do
go ahead forgive me let me ask you
should i use a debt consolidation no or
should i hire an attorney no you should
go do this do this myself yeah she'll
give me the best field personally yes
well it's a hassle i gave you a new job
it's a nice i understand well let me
tell you debt consolidation doesn't work
at all they're they're just going to
throw the thing in another pile and
create another mess for you that's
another scam group uh and an attorney by
the time you finish paying them you're
going to wish you'd done it yourself and
they are not going to be as efficient as
you're going to be it's your new hobby
how many different accounts do you think
there is
open for debt probably five
only five
you borrow 30 000 bucks a piece on these
things
yeah oh well this is a lot easier than i
thought then
you have to do five deals by phone come
on man
all right i i just don't even know who
to call well you're the last person that
had the account
and they'll tell you
they just call them we sold it also
yeah you know i'm calling about this
account we sold it who'd you sell it to
i need to get in touch with them i need
to settle it and also pull up a copy of
your credit bureau report it'll pop up
on there maybe who owns it because
they're probably dinging you like crazy
trying to get the money out of you there
definitely but you need to correlate and
so here's the thing okay
do not pay more than the original
principal balance you don't morally owe
more than that they're going to come
after you for a lot more than that
if you want to argue for a little less
you're welcome to but you've got the
money i wouldn't i would just pay what i
owe
it's only 150 000 bucks after all said
and done here okay the third thing is
always get it in writing they get no
money unless you have in writing
before you send money
in writing exactly what the amount is
and the last thing is under no
circumstances do you give them
electronic access to your checking
account
because they lie and they will take the
22 000 out after you settle them with
them for 12 000
and try getting it back then yeah that's
a pain in the butt email okay
email is fine i want it in writing and
you can either take a prepaid debit card
for each one of these or 30 grand a
piece approximately
or you can have a separate checking
account that just has that money in it
only but do not allow them access to
multiple dollars beyond what you are
settling with them for in writing
five different people you got to track
down and do deals with
and this is your penance
this is you paying back you know this is
you working through and cleaning up the
mess that you made
and it's not that hard actually you can
do it
and and i'm i'm proud of you for
attempting it and if you need some help
as you're working through it you call me
back anytime in writing no electronic
access to your checking account don't
give them any more than was originally
owed when this all started